My name is Brent Beer.
I'm one of the trainers here at GitHub.
Which usually entails sometimes doing online classes.
Classes in person.
Or sometimes, with Enterprise customers doing private courses, as well.
So, one of the things that confuses people, often, when they first start is,
well, I know, I've heard about Git and I've heard about GitHub.
You know? What is the difference between the two?
And Git, itself, being the version control tool that GitHub is built on.
So, Git is largely the thing that will be interacting with on the laptop.
Doing that local work first and as soon as we use a few choice commands and
send things up to GitHub that's when it's more the social component or
it's in it's network, it's in a cloud if you wanted to use that term as well.
So Git is local.
GitHub is where we share and collaborate with other people.
The reason why I like pull request is because it allows us to, really get
that work that we're wanting to, kind of, work on, and complete that feature.
And allow us to collaborate with other people just to show them our work.
Get feedback on it.
So that we can have people kind of working with us as they choose to or
as we want to pull other people into the work itself.
When GitHub started you know, a few years ago kind of a, as a out of a need for
the Ruby community to have ways to kind of share their code and collaborate.
It's expanded past that and now, you know, a lot more open source communities
and languages have, you know, grown within GitHub and the GitHub ecosystem.
So, GitHub helped the open source community and, and
helped make it a little bit better by allowing us to have this centralized place
where we can talk about any features that we're wanting to work on.
Any problems that we might have as we decide to share code around or
incorporate code into other projects so
it helps the communities kind of have that place where they can pull together,
talk about their new features and work through problems together.
In fact, the node community itself is one of the larger communities that
first started out after GitHub was already around.
So, they were able to flourish as a community, whereas other communities maybe
were older and came to GitHub later and then grew from there.